one of the things I like to sort of poke
at is like the man cave notion guys are
guys are proud of their man caves sort
of thing and it's a little house is mine
you know like could you imagine talking
to like a Roman legion or
one of these guys and be like you know
I've got my man cave why don't you come
over and hang out in my garage and I've
got some beers in the fridge in there
and a TV like you know what I mean you
know the notion you know today where men
lead and they've got Authority and
they're masculine you know sort of stuff
it's like they get sequestered to like
the bastards you know stepchild that has
to hide underneath the stairs with the
whole man cave notion I just you know I
just think that they're you know for
wimps and for guys that are controlled
well all the Modern Man Cave really is
is a shrine to other men that are
putting their den in the universe I mean
yeah you're right everybody's basement
or man cave and it's there's jerseys on
the wall of names that aren't theirs and
it's sports memorabilia and it's just oh
this is where I get to go and watch the
game every Sunday and drink the beer and
watch other guys chase their dream while
I fiddle away you know it's like
I've only done it for the last few years
because it's it's one way to keep track
in touch with some some guys that I used
to you know be in touch with but the
whole fantasy sports thing is just such
a weird concept the more that I think
about it and that not only the concept
itself but who has got the time I mean
the people that are best at this kind of
thing have to you know I'm looking and
seeing like oh I don't know I've got
whoever is playing this coming Sunday
and
it turns out the guy got hurt and he's
out for the entire year like now my
entire season is like torpedoed and but
and but though I don't know what's going
on like I I'm so busy I have so many
other things that I'm worried on worried
about
bragging that you're a fantasy football
or a fantasy Sports Champion is
basically just saying you have no life
because you have to constantly be
checking on things you have to
constantly be watching stats and injury
reports and putting together the perfect
lineup and it's just
I I've decided that this is the very
last year I'll ever participate in
anything like this I'd rather do you
know daily bets on teams and games and
stuff like that but uh you know this
this kind of like long form
gambling or watching other men fantasy
that don't know my name and will never
care about me play sports is is kind of
played out at this point but Mike that's
a great yeah on that
um I just started my YouTube channel in
Romanian and
it seems that there's a big discussion
right now about influencers in Romania
having connections with the gambling
sites
that they're not responsible because
they're promoting gambling sites to kids
and I got this question from somebody
right like when you're going to be a big
I know influencer in Romania
um will you be talking or promoting
gambling sites or services like yes if
they're mine
if it's my business and if I have a
direct interest to promote it without
being
amoral and without hurting anybody I
[__] will yeah otherwise what's the
point the thing which is all you do
there's a lot of these affiliate
programs
well a lot of these Affiliates you know
that you deal with
um my experience is hold on a second
just realized my volume's real low how's
that is that better yeah you're good
yeah that's good no just wondering why
that knob was all the way down there
um you know my experience with like
these affiliate programs is the vast
majority of them where you promote other
people's things whether it happens to be
I don't care because you know a program
a course or something like that
um they're mostly [__] and
um I mean look man I get like
messages from like a skin care product I
saw this morning right and it's like
this is a very well-known name and you
would see it all over the Internet and
many other people's channels saying that
you know there's like a seven step
program and you use this in the morning
and this in the night they sent me one
of their sample packages like a year and
a half ago and
if you guys have followed me for a while
you guys know that I'm very familiar
with Dr Anthony J and his book Esther
generation I've had my DNA analyzed
we've you know we've looked through all
this and I know it's an endocrine
disruptor and what's not an endocrine
disruptor then everything that they put
in that skincare line is an endocrine
disruptor it's [__] and people don't
look at these things they just blindly
you know go in and promote it it's like
oh you know there's a product that
they'll ship out all I have to do is
mention it it's like I've made that
mistake in the past too where I've just
you know put other people's [__] in
front of my audience on the channel and
I don't do that anymore it's like if
it's not something that I'm intimately
you know familiar with inside and out
it's never mentioned man it's like you
have to be really really careful with
your reputation I don't think people
take that seriously enough because
there's some real dip shits out there
that maybe they don't intentionally try
to hurt you or Rob you or misinform you
but they tend to do it anyway because
they're not together like they're not
sorted yeah yeah it's all marketing
there's another
example here of a situation like this
that a lot of Romanians that are looking
at the show right now know about this
super big influencer that promoted a
scam regarding solar panels
and
now he's just playing the victim oh I
didn't know I got scammed as well like
dude you're responsible
yeah it looks like the guys that
promoted the FTX thing right like
there's a lot of people that got in [__]
for that and they're like well I didn't
know any better well why are you
promoting it then right you were you
were listening to Michael friends easy
recently and and if you listen to Sammy
the Bulls podcast if you introduce
someone in the mob and you said this is
a friend of ours yeah you're dead if
he's not made you know so and it's the
same thing you you make an intro to
someone you better be sure or if you
stand behind their product you better be
sure you have to say he's a friend of
mine
yeah well if he yeah if he's a friend of
mine he's not in but if he's a friend of
ours so essentially yeah that's it but
back to your point earlier I'm off in in
ancient Rome they kept the population
associated with food drink and chariot
races which is the modern equivalent of
the NFL now I don't mind watching the
odd NFL game but when I used to hang out
with people in Virginia before they'd
spend all day a Saturday drinking beer
watching and college football then
they'd spend all their Sunday drinking
beer watching the NFL and you can count
down over one hand how many of them were
jacked
no it's like I get the fascination for
the whole fantasy league stuff my dad
and my brother do it with some other
family members and cousins and stuff and
I just it's like what's the ROI in this
like you're spending hours upon hours
putting together a fake team and then
the pot payout it's like 200 bucks and
some little shitty plastic trophy that
you get to like a couple hundred dollars
put on your [__] mantel piece and
pretend like 100. 16 16 weeks worth of
like what can you do with that time that
would be you know paying you off better
um I understand if you play sports too
because I used to watch sports when I
played sports but the minute as a guy if
you play any sports your career will
always end at some point maybe that's in
high school college maybe minor leagues
maybe you'll have to retire you because
you hit the wall like that's actually
where hitting the wall came from for
athletes when they were too old to play
and that's where you know how talented
you are like I was fortunate I wasn't
probably good enough to play at a usd1
maybe not even a D3 school but I played
down here for a couple years and then I
got to the point like all right I'm not
good enough to go to the next level and
then focused on something else so in
doing so I stopped watching sports but
when you're in it and you're trying to
get ahead yeah yeah I liked watching
sports see like what the the pros are
doing I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out